okay let's get started so my goal this
morning is to give you an outline of the
proof of this result one thing I'd like
to emphasize is I added the first name
of my collaborator Ava pointed out that
mu N is a very popular Vietnamese name
and and so I want to make sure that the
town is not lost parenthetically town
was actually a ver student and I'm and
I'm eternally grateful that she sent him
my way as a postdoc so I'm going to do
I'm going to outline the proof of this
argument and along the way there'll be a
couple of historical digressions that I
hope you will find of independent of an
interest so what I'm going to do first
is simply set up a linear program to
figure out a feasible assignment of
doctors to hospitals then I'm going to
restate scoffs lemma again ok so what
are the variables I need X of little D H
is one if single dr. D is assigned to
hospital h and 0 otherwise x of c comma
h h prime is 1 so c refers to a couple
and remember the ordering i use is the
first member of the couple is female the
second member is male so this is one if
the female is assigned to hospital h and
the male is assigned to hospital h prime
notice in this notation CH h prime is
different from c h prime H and then the
other variable is both members of the
couple are assigned to the same hospital
those are the only decision variables
and the constraints you get are the
obvious ones so first every single
doctor can be assigned to at most one
hospital every couple can be assigned to
at most one pair of slots
and finally if I look at a hospital the
total number of single doctors the total
number of single person from each couple
female total number of males from each
couple alone as well as both has to be
less than or equal to the capacity of
the hospital I'd like you to notice that
we have a pesky to here which means that
this constraint matrix is not totally
unimodular so the extreme points of this
will not be integral okay okay let's go
back to what scoffs lemma says so scoffs
lemma says we have a non-negative matrix
yes things become much easier if I
didn't allow couples to go to the same
hospital so let me check whether you'd
have total unimodular rity I would still
not be totally unimodular because this
variable can appear at in three
constraints right so it's not
immediately obvious that that's going to
be totally unimodular yeah if you just
remove the on the seconds some in each
of the second and third sometimes if you
remove the condition that H prime does
not equal age yes with the fourth with
the fourth summit right I mean you would
count everything exactly it's not not
only sub mother earth doesn't matter no
no I'm just asking oh I see for sentence
of you guys so I so the the okay you're
absolutely right i could have just said
this is overall h prime H and then this
wouldn't appear I think the only reason
we I think the only this is to make it
clear I guess our viewers in terms of
the exposition was to make it clear that
you have to count the fact that you
either get one member of the couple or
you get both members of the couple that
was it okay sir ya know nothing I know
nothing deeper than that just
okay okay let's go back to scoffs lemma
now I must have a non-negative matrix
and a right-hand side vector every
component of the right-hand side vector
must be strictly positive and I'm
looking at this polyhedron ax less than
or equal to B every row has a strict
ordering over the columns that intersect
it so the easiest let me follow ever
suggestion from yesterday think of the
matrix a as being 0 1 and every row as
being an agent then every column of the
matrix you can interpret as the
incidence vector of some subset or
coalition of agents and then when an
agent has a preference ordering over
columns that's a preference ordering
over the coalition's that they would
like to be a part of okay now when you
pick a vector X and the polyhedron all
we really care about is which components
of X are positive the actual value is
irrelevant for us for the moment so
imagine a central planner chooses X pay
attention only to the components of X
that are positive let's interpret that
to mean that the central planner would
like the following coalition's to fall
now pick a component of X that is 0 this
corresponds to a coalition not selected
by the central planner your job is to
persuade the agents to accept this
coalition so you go to each of the
agents in this chosen coalition and you
ask would you like to be a part of this
coalition or remain with one of the
coalition's chosen by the central
planner the dominance condition says
that for that there's at least one agent
who will say I'm happy with the
coalition chosen by the central planner
okay so for every coalition not chosen
by the central planner if you approach
the agents there is at least one agent
so there is at least one row such that
that agent says I prefer every column
chosen by the central planner to the
column that you're proposing that's the
dominance condition and the result is
that this polyhedron must have an
extreme point that dominates every
column in other words no matter what
column you select there will be an agent
who will veto that particular color yes
quite see how it matches your narrative
Sony your nerd if it seems to assume
that X R is zero and that doesn't seem
to be stated here ah so the that's why I
have greater than or equal to here right
so the interesting cases when X R is
zero because we think of that as the
blocking the potentially blocking
coalition and so in that case you would
have strict right so nobody wants to
join a coalition not selected by the
central planner okay okay well let's go
back to this I have a polyhedron ax less
than or equal to B every component on
the right-hand side is positive every
coefficient is non-negative in the a
matrix what else do I need every row
must have a strict ordering over the
columns well here's the row associated
with the single doctors every doctor is
equipped with a strict preference
ordering over hospitals I can use that
preference ordering over hospitals to be
the ordering over the variables X of D H
let's go to the next row couples every
couple is equipped with a strict
preference ordering over pairs of
hospitals I can use that preference
ordering here now let's go to hospitals
he got number one hospitals were not
characterized by a preference ordering
hospitals were characterized by a choice
function remember what the choice
function was every hospital assigns to
an individual doctor a score and then if
you present them with a list of doctors
they select the K highest-scoring
doctors on the list that does not give
me a preference ordering over pairs okay
so what are we going to do so this is
what I just said what we're going to do
is we're going to use the choice
function to induce an ordering over the
variable so I'm going to make up an
ordering but the catch is the ordering
that eye makeup has to have the
following property anything that is
dominating with respect to that ordering
must correspond to a stable matching in
the sense that I defined yesterday you
can't do this in general we can do this
because we have responsive preferences
right but notice we are now restricting
the set of possible stable matches
because there could be stable matches
out there that we will not recover using
this device so in this sense we're
making our problem harder
so fine supposing we have such an
ordering scoffs lemma tells me that this
polyhedron will have a dominating
extreme point because this is not
totally unimodular that dominating
extreme point will be fractional doesn't
correspond to our matching what are we
going to do next we're going to round
that fractionally stable solution into
an integer solution that preserves
stability and the whole game will be to
show that that rounding doesn't violate
the capacity constraints too much okay
for the first line torture so you have
some variables that have only one that's
right so in other words functions or
this so the way we're going to use the
choice function to so ordering these is
easy I will simply use the skull that
you have assigned to the individual dr.
ok how do i order this actually this is
the more interesting case okay I look at
the member of the couple with the lowest
score in your ordering and compare that
with the score you give to this so in
some sense i look at the worst member of
the couple from my point of view and i
use that to determine the ordering okay
now a little bit of work is required to
show that if a solution is dominating
with respect to that ordering it
corresponds to a stable matching
basically i prefer the worst guy in the
couple to the doctor if that's true then
then you are happy with a couple but
notice where you know in but this
doesn't capture all stable magics right
okay
everyone with me so far ok now the
rounding we're going to use iterative
rounding but here's the first historical
digression I want to tell you about the
Shapley folkman style Emma two reasons
to do that number one if you look at
this you will see that this is really an
iterative rounding method that gives you
a very crude bound the second reason I
want to do this is because it represents
one of the earliest attempts in economic
theory to talk about approximation and
this would be in 1965 so well before
cooked 71 paper and the subsequent work
on worst case bounce okay let me tell
you about the Shapley folkman style ever
so first of all why are there three
names shapleigh and focalin in personal
correspondence with each other came up
with dilemma but it was never published
until star-69 paper where he uses the
lemma to prove an approximation result
for competitive equilibrium the reason
for the Shapley Shapley folkman not
publishing is that folk Minh committed
suicide soon after the correspondence
correspondence was not the cause okay
sir folkman is actually John folkman is
actually a rather sad case he committed
suicide five years after getting his PhD
and he is important for oriented
metroids and if you look at the book on
Ramsey theory by Rothschild Spencer and
stiglitz you will see here as one of the
earliest theorems and additive
combinatorics on arithmetic progressions
so rather incredible individual so here
is the lemma start with a collection of
sets in RM these sets do not have to be
convex
look at the men kofsky some of the
convex hull pick anything in the men cut
in the minkowski sum you can write it as
a sum of vectors where each XJ comes
from the convex hull of s J so far this
is utterly trivial because I said that
be was in the minkowski sum okay the
non-trivial part is that you can
actually choose these X J's so that a
large number of them actually live in SJ
not just the convex hull of SJ so
remember n is the number of sets m is
the dimension of the space and I think
it'd be useful to look at a toy example
so let me show you three sets
s1 s2 s3 now what would a picture of
that look like well s 1 is 0 0 the
origin and 0 1 so that means s 1
consists of these two points s2 consists
of the origin and this point as 3
consists of the origin and this point
now the min cut now the convex hull of
each of these is are the following
intervals what's the min kofsky son well
pick a point in here pick a point in
here pick a point in here so I've picked
one point from each of the convex hulls
add them together what point am I going
to get I'm going to get this one so for
example this is a half a half now it's
not hard to see that you're basically
going to fill all of this up now pick a
point in the minkowski sum here it is a
half half now according to this we
should be able to represent it as the
sum of three vectors because I have
three sets s we live in two dimensions
so one of those three vectors will
actually be one of the points in the
corresponding s and what would that be
in this example let's see I should have
thought about this ahead of time but
maybe you can help me the origin is one
of the variables choose the origin and
oh
great okay I mean n minus M because the
number of sets is larger than the
dimension so here we're in two
dimensions right I have three sets okay
then that salvation oh I'm sorry yes
this summation should go to I'm sorry
yes they should go to end my apologies
okay now why on earth is this useful let
me make a slight change let a be an M by
n 0 1 matrix be a vector of right-hand
sides I have more columns than Rose
denote each column of the a matrix by a
superscript J and let s superscript JB
this set so every column gets its own
set consisting of the column and the
origin now supposing you give me a
vector B that can be written as ax star
where each of the X stars is between 0 &
1 well that's another way of saying that
B is in the main kowski some of the
convex hull of the s J's agreed ok so by
the Shapley folkman style emma b can be
written as a sum of vectors YJ where the
y JS are between 0 and 1 with at least n
minus one of them being either 0 or 1
right because if the value y is 1 you're
putting weight on on the on the
depending on the order you're putting
weight on this if the value Y is 0
you're putting weight on this
translation i can write be as as a as a
as a linear combination of the age
days where most of the linear
multipliers are either 0 or 1 so in
other words why has at most M fractional
components let y star be obtained by
rounding up each fractional component a
y star minus B in the L infinity norm
has to be smaller than yes yeah yeah
it's exactly so this is exactly right so
for those of you who haven't figured it
out there is only one idea in linear
optimization let me tell you what that
is and that's and that idea is going to
be used here
you have a feasible system of equations
and let's suppose you're optimizing some
function over this and the optimal is
let's call it X star you're currently at
some feasible solution X bar what can
you say about this well this has to be
in the null space of a does that make
sense okay that's the secret to
optimization find a vector in the null
space that's improving follow most
algorithms for linear programming do
this even the augmenting path algorithm
so network flows the blossom algorithm
of edmonds they're all finding a vector
in the null space and then moving in an
improving direction okay this is
basically what's baked into the car
theodora theorem the Shapley folkman
style emma and the iterative rounding
method you're simply going to add enough
column so that the null space is
non-trivial that gives you a direction
of improvement move in that direction
you're going to have to pay something
for that you'll see how much you pay as
I go along any questions I mean you seem
surprised to me points of the photo oh I
thought nickel was saying is that is
what's driving this the fact that I have
more columns than Rose sorry did I
misunderstand the question yes ok so i
guess i was reading it as I have more
columns than Rose my null space is going
to be non-empty so if I find the
direction of improvement in the null
space some components will be pushed up
to 1 some components will be pushed down
to zero and i have and i still have a
representation you use i'll write this
out you'll see this written out in a
moment
ok now
I'm sure many of you are looking at this
and saying not much of a bound and
that's because you have the benefit of
50 years so I want you to think about
this in circa nineteen sixty-five so
Edmonds is paper on the algorithm for
non bipartite matching has only just
appeared and that's the paper in which
he says that the measure of a good
algorithm is that its difficulty should
increase algebraically with the size of
the graph as I said cooks paper doesn't
appear until 71 and then I fan kristef
Edie's of worst-case bound for the
Traveling Salesman doesn't appear in
unpublished form until 1976 nevertheless
there are still some interesting things
that you can do with this and i want to
show you to the first is due to ross
star which is a notion of approximation
for a competitive equilibrium when some
of the preferences do not satisfy the
usual concavity assumption on utilities
but let me first give you the proof of
the Shapley folkman style emma suppose B
is equal to this where you've got at
least this many components of why being
fractional that's the thing we want to
contradict so let's see be the sub
matrix of a that corresponds to the
integer components of y and c barbie the
sub matrix of a that corresponds to the
fractional components of y so i can
write be like this right these are the
fractional these are the integer
ok
take the integer ones over to the other
side then be- this is equal to this
these are just the fractional components
now remember we're in dimension M so
this matrix has m rows we've made the
assumption that there are at least M
plus 1 fractional components so this
matrix has more columns than rose as it
has more columns than Rose the colonel
of the null space must be non-empty pick
a vector in the kernel and now look at
this vector here notice b minus c YC is
equal to this remember every component
of y bar c is fractional meaning it's
strictly bigger than 0 strictly smaller
than 1 so i can choose a lambda small
enough so that as i travel along z some
of those y components are going down to
zero others are going up to 1 keep
moving until you bump into one of those
constraints at that point you've reduced
the number of fractional components by
one and you still have a representation
of be this argument breaks down the
moment you have em or fewer fractional
components that's the argument and those
of you who remember your proof of the
kara theodora theorem will recognize
it's exactly the same proof
ok
now if you look at arrow and han chapter
7 that's devoted entirely to the study
of competitive equilibrium with
nonconvex ities either in the cost
function increasing returns to scale
which was a bad example that Christos
mentioned yesterday or nonconvex ities
and preferences and curiously enough
they open that chapter with a quotation
from Milton and to describe why that
case is difficult a gulf profound as the
Simonian bog betwixt amisha and mount
cassia sold where armies Oh whole have
sunk so by the way sir bony and bog is
what used to be called quagmire before
the Vietnam War you will not find people
using that term anymore for quagmire
they use quagmire instead and the reason
they picked I think this quote is
because if you look at Milton's Paradise
Lost the word convexity arises at least
three times so the problem that star set
himself was this I want to look at the
traditional exchange economy with non
convex preferences in other words the
upper contour sets of your utility
functions are non convex parenthetically
those of you who still teach and
research general equilibrium i'm looking
at Chris if I could see her right there
here's a suggestion change this to the
sharing economy ok and that will make
general equilibrium sexy once again ok
so the set up that stock considers is
that you have more agents than goods and
what's the theorem he identifies a price
vector P star and a feasible allocation
with the property that at most M agents
do not receive a utility maximizing
bundle at the price pista yeah what do
you do with these agents you talk to
them
alright everyone with you so far okay
and then at the end I'll show you and
actually a clever little observation of
Kenneth arrow that gets a little more
mileage out of this result right so you
I is agent eyes utility function e I is
agent eyes endowment and now remember
the upper contour sets are no longer
convex sets so what does an upper come
to a set look like for the typical agent
it's going to look something like this
so here is the customary budget line and
here is the usual non convex upper
contour set right the set of allocations
that give you more utility then you can
achieve anywhere here is not a convex
set ok so here's the first thing that
star suggests replace the upper contour
set that you see here by its convex hull
now you have a convex up a calm to a set
that corresponds to a quasi concave
utility function you're good to go in
terms of applying arrow debris McKenzie
compute the competitive equilibrium with
respect to those you stars which are
which is the rebbe utility function
those exist let x i star be the
valuation equilibrium of that particular
economy or a valuation equilibrium of
that particular economy now we're going
to apply Shapley folk minh star what are
the sets well one set is the negative of
all of the endowments so that's the
total supply in the economy z star is
the excess demand and since we picked a
valuation equilibrium of that modified
economy the excess demand is 0 so that
means 0 is in the convex hull of the
minkowski sum of the following sets what
are the sets s 1 up to SN it's the set
of bundles that maximize your true
utility with respect to the budget line
given by the equilibrium prices of the
modified economy in other words what
does your set si look like it's this
that's the convex hull of the set si
now Shapley folkman star says that since
zero can be written like this by the
Shapley folkman style emma you can write
zero as a combination of things where it
look at most a small number will not be
either here or here because these are
the bundles that actually maximize your
utility at the given prices so some
agents at most M of them will end up
with a bundle somewhere here okay so
let's suppose you end up with this
bundle here is arrows observation which
parenthetically does not appear in arrow
in hand it actually appears in a paper
on on racial discrimination don't ask me
why this observation appears here but
here it is take this individual and
clone them so each individual in your
economy is now cloned a large number of
times let's suppose this bundle is fifty
percent of this plus fifty percent of
this take your clones of that individual
give fifty percent of them this bundle
and the other fifty percent of them this
bundle that's it done so with the
economy is large enough nonconvex ities
and preferences are not a problem ok now
this argument doesn't work with
production because it's a little hard to
imagine making large numbers of clones
with firms with increasing returns to
scale
it's yes so what's also important here
is that you have many more agents than
you have goods oh yes that okay but the
in other words the clone into the clone
you know the clone argument is a way of
formalizing the intuition that is if you
have a large enough number of agents so
that the individual nonconvex ities
should wash out and in fact if you go
back to the way that Shapley Folkman and
originally stated their lemma you can
act they say to their lemma in the
following form the minkowski sum of a
large number of sets is approximately
convex and you can think of that as sort
of a central limit theorem analog for
convex sets and if you want to know more
about this interpretation actually sit
out Siddharth barman right so right so
Siddharth is much more up to date on
these things than I am he would be the
person to ask about these other
interpretations of Shapley folkman star
okay let me just give you one other
application suppose you wish to maximize
an additively separable function subject
to linear constraints I'm imposing no
conditions on the f other than it should
have enough conditions for an optimal to
exist same idea star replace each FJ by
the smallest concave function that fits
right above it
and now solve this problem
let each a be the error in approximating
f by f star and now if you apply the
Shapley folkman style ma it says the
solution to this problem evaluated with
respect to the true objective function
value is at least as large as the object
as this objective function value less
the error term but notice the error term
only comes from M of the functions f not
all of them so once again if you have
many more functions than you have
constraints you get you get perhaps in
in subjective terms a reasonable
approximation you're sorting them in
decreasing order so these would be the
the largest errors so the largest yet
these are the largest errors yeah okay
now we could apply Shapley folkman style
directly to the matching problem solve
the matching problem it has many more
variables than it does rose because you
have a variable for each single doctor
hospital and for each couple and pair of
hospitals that's clearly larger than the
number of doctors then the number of
couples plus the number of hospitals the
bound you're going to get is not helpful
at all and the reason it's not helpful
is Shapley folkman style doesn't allow
you to control which constraints to
violate you cannot assign a single
doctor to three hospitals that's a
constraint that cannot be violated the
degree of violation M is large because
you're making no use at all about any
information about the a matrix the
Shapley folkman style emma is too
general the main idea we're going to use
here is that our a matrix in some sense
is very sparse and that sparsity allows
us to reduce the bound here and so the
bounds that you're going to get will
depend on the sparsity of the a matrix
okay so with in computer science they've
been to iterative rounding methods carol
allowance in 2008 gandhi kula Pavarotti
sreenivasan in 2006 really they only
differ in how they choose a vector in
the null space but the basic idea is the
same and unlike Shapley folkman star
they're making use of the structure of
the a matrix okay so that's the
innovation over Shapley folkman star
we're going to exploit the iterative
rounding method is described here by
corale lowensohn okay and I'm going to
Prime going to outline a proof for us
for a weaker version of the claim
because I can fit things all on to the
slides which is simply that hospital by
hospital we will not violate the
capacities by more than three notice I
have not put down a bound on the
aggregate violation okay so here's the
iterative rounding method choose an
extreme point that optimizes your
favorite objective function over a
polyhedron if X star is integral go home
you're done
if X star is fractional then you go on
to the next step any component of X
style that is integral either 0 or 1
you're going to freeze at that value for
the remainder of the algorithm now if a
variable is frozen 20 you simply throw
that out of your program if a variable
is fixed at one that variable is
consuming resources that's either a
doctor who is assigned or a hospital
that must have its capacity decremented
by the appropriate amount so when I say
fix the value I mean also adjust the
right-hand sides of the linear program
to account for the fact that you have
fixed the value now at some point you're
going to end up with a solution where
the X stars are all fractional the
components of the X star every component
is strictly between 0 and 1 this is the
stage where you're going to do the
rounding so C are the columns of a that
correspond to the non integer valued
coordinates of x star these correspond
to the integer valued take the integer
valued over to the other side you have
this smaller linear program to solve
if every coordinate of X star is
fractional you're going to delete a
certain row I haven't told you what that
row is but you're going to delete a row
why do you want to do this well when you
delete the row you're going to end up in
a situation where the null space is
non-empty and that's going to give you a
direction of improvement when you make
that direction of improvement you're
going to violate the row that you
deleted but if you're careful about
which row you deleted you can guarantee
that that violation will not be too
large solve the updated linear program
which now has fewer rows than it did
before and continue so at each stage
you're throwing out constraints you're
throwing out constraints that you know
will be evaluated in the future but
you're choosing them in such a way that
the violations will not be too large
okay so we start with an extreme point
solution to this problem which extreme
point solution the dominating one that
comes from scarf now in this iterative
rounding method any variable that is
zero remains at zero
okay now why is that important it means
that at the end of this procedure the
integer solution we get will satisfy the
dominance condition okay
here is the claim we can round X star
into a zero one solution X bar so that
no doctor or couple is a site no doctor
is assigned to more than one hospital no
couple is assigned to more than one pair
of slots every hospitals capacity
constraint is violated by at most three
every hospitals capacity constraint
declines by it at most three okay so
here's the claim if you're in a
situation where every component of X
star is fractional strictly between zero
and one the claim is you must be able to
find a hospital that satisfies this
condition or a hospital that satisfies
this condition just pay attention to the
top one what am i doing I'm taking every
variable and I'm rounding it up since
every variable is strictly between zero
and one everything is rounded up to one
and I'm saying when I do that I violate
that hospitals capacity constrained by
at most three now if such a constraint
existed think about what it means if I
throw this constraint away any
subsequent rounding you do cannot
violate this ignored constraint by more
than three okay how do we know that such
a constraint can exist again I said
don't pay attention to this this one is
not the interesting one well let's think
about our constraint matrix each
variable does not appear in too many
rows in fact if you ignore this each
variable appears at most three times so
I have a constraint matrix where the
number of nonzero entries in any column
is at most three and if you cannot find
such a constraint it must mean
that in every constraint this must be
true in other words every hospital
intersects at least this many positive
variables so now think about it every
column has only three nonzero entries
you have to arrange these three nonzero
entries so as to stuff every hospital
constraint now it's more than just
counting there's an added assumption we
make use of the X style we started with
is an extreme point so that mean that's
another constraint how you arrange those
nonzero entries has to form a linearly
independent set of columns all of that
together is hard to do and that's the
contradiction that kills off this
possibility and this possibility so the
kind of constraint we're looking for
exists
that's the essence of the argument now
if you want an aggregate bound then all
that happens is over here you put in an
additional constraint that says the
total amount of capacity should be less
than or equal to the amount of capacity
you've used plus 9 you run through the
same argument but now notice as you add
in more constraints the number of
nonzero entries in each column gets
larger and larger which means it's going
to be harder and harder to find a
constraint that you can throw away
unless you increase the error bounds in
the full version of the paper we do it
for more than just couples agents can
have preferences over bundles of size
alpha and the bounds are all in terms of
alpha extra constraint also has to have
preferences that extra constraint also
has to have preferences or know where
you can add that in at the rounding
stage yeah so that's a you know because
because once you've got because we'd
since we never wrap anything that was
zero remains at zero you're only trying
to control the things that round up you
can throw in extra constraints to limit
the amount of rounding that's taking
place
yes so you have missed something so
right it is minus 3 console ah that's
because right so okay so this is what I
wanted to prove so the way we did that
was we put in two extra constraints that
says after the rounding you never
violate by more than three up never
violate by more than three down now how
did we know to pick three the answer is
you try a number it doesn't work yeah
you go back and you readjust
okay now how much time do I have it and
it's okay so that's good I will not pile
Pellaeon upon ossa and show you a proof
of scouts lemma but for those of you who
are interested it's very short I'm happy
to show it to you offline what I'd like
to do is close with some open problems
yes when you present in this result
yesterday yes nine there right well some
additional guarantee it comes from a
similar argument we throw in an extra
constraint to say that the aggregate
capacity must be less than or equal to
the given capacity plus nine right and
so now because we've added in another
row that means there are more nonzero
entries in each column and so that
pushes up the bound of all three to a 49
because it works in the actual page I
mean the facetious answer is 2 squared +
3 squared that's deep right yeah but the
in in the in the paper you will see the
bound in terms of alpha where alpha
represents the size of the largest
bundle any agent is interested in so on
these ones it grows linearly with alpha
on the aggregate it grows quadratically
with alpha okay another thing okay so
let me just do them in this order you
could imagine the following since
couples are the main obstacle it might
be interesting to get an error bound in
terms of the proportion of couples and
so the flavor of the theorem should be
as the fraction of couples declines
you're at you know the approximation
gets better and better okay the second
thing is notice that in order to use
scoffs lemma here we started with a
choice function and then we had to make
up preferences it would be nice to avoid
that step altogether so one question is
the following what about a version of
scoffs lemma for choice functions I
don't know what that would be tan and I
have an idea about how to do it for
certain kinds of choice functions
so we could imagine it could be done for
other kinds of choice functions now why
would that be interesting the positive
results for many to many matching that
we have for choice functions that have a
path independence property and Federico
who is sitting next to you on your left
is the person to ask about this and and
those theorems work by using the
deferred acceptance algorithm but there
is no reason for existence to be tied to
a particular algorithm and so scoffs
lemma suggests the possibility of
existence results for choice functions
which may not satisfy the path
independence property okay so that's
open question number one sorry number
two open question number three is that
in the statement of scarce lemma the a
matrix is non-negative every entry here
has to be non-negative if you look
carefully at the at one of the proofs of
scoffs lemma I don't think you really
need that I think you can allow some
negative entries and so that would be
useful because that would allow us to
capture other kinds of constraints that
we can't capture simply using a
non-negative a matrix okay next open
problem is side constraints able raise
this issue yesterday which is we would
like to add side constraints but in
order to use scoffs lemma you would then
need to impose an ordering over the
columns for the agent associated with
that side constraint now the problem
with that is that under the dominance
condition you don't want dominance to be
to rely on these extra side constraints
that you've thrown in so is there a way
to do scoffs lemma with some kinds of
side constraints don't know the answer
to that but again one can think of
extensions to matching problems for
which that would be useful
last complexity what was the algorithm
find a dominating extreme point I didn't
say how we do that scoff gives us an
algorithm to do that which is very
similar to the Lemke house and pivoting
algorithm but that's a general-purpose
algorithm for our particular problem
it's possible that there might be a
polynomial time version why do I think
that well without couples we know that
they exists that there must exist a
polynomial time algorithm to find the
dominating extreme point it's the gale
Shapley deferred acceptance algorithm
now if I think about the polyhedron for
Gail Shapley without couples that's a
network flow problem and the extreme
points correspond to spanning trees this
is a generalized network flow problem
that's I think this is the reason why I
wrote it down that way because okay and
we know what the extreme points of this
look like they're basically spanning
trees with a single edge and we know at
least from the cardinality version of
these problems that many of the
algorithms so network flows can easily
be adapted to generalized networks you
can ask Ava about that all right so that
makes me think that perhaps one can do
something here we don't our algorithm is
apply scoffs pivoting rule and then the
rounding is simply a sequence of linear
programs and the linear programs that
we're solving a polynomial in the size
of the in the natural measure of the
size of the problem but one can ask more
generally what other instances of
scarves lemma our polynomial e solvable
so I'll end here unless there are
questions yes
oh but in the way that I stated it it
it's it's not clear that way but in the
way that Shapley folkman originally
wrote it so let me just give you the
verbal description the minkowski sum of
any of a large number of sets is
approximately convex and the reason why
I might want why might why one might
want to think of that as a sort of
central limit theorem 4 sets is think
about the central limit theorem a sum of
a large number of independent random
variables no matter what distribution
they come from are approximately
normally distributed so it is in that
sense now the idea that i just gave
actually has been formalized by people
working in analysis and probability
their us so that you should ask the bath
bomb and there is a square root of n yes
okay the reason we did is because we
started with a fractional solution that
was that's had the dominating property
and what you have to observe is the
following if you take a subset of those
variables and round them up that is
still dominating so we never take a zero
variable and round it up that would
screw up everything so zero variables
remain zero all that happens is some
variables that were previously positive
will be rounded down to zero but nothing
that is zero is ever rounded up yes
that's a good question I don't know of
any I don't know of any way of doing
that I suspect that that that would have
to depend on the Preferences the
preferences of the hospitals or the
Preferences of so I don't believe that
would I my suspicion is the universe the
universal bound would be very bad it
would probably grow with the size of the
problem but under plausible restrictions
on preferences I think something might
be possible yes because we never throw
them out of the program right so we
never throw those out of the program
they're always they're the only ones we
throw out other capacity constraints and
we're only throwing out the capacity
constraints that we know will not be
violated too much not remember we're all
we throw out a constraint and weary
solve the linear program so we don't in
other words the remaining variables are
never forcibly rounded up the algorithm
terminates when the linear program
returns with a solution that is integer
super thanks very much